[Aplausos]
la suya Fue una carrera musical de siete
décadas que empezó en el arant
con su marido a ikearner la canción de
los 60 full In Love sobre una relación
Abusiva les convirtió en estrellas
[Música]
con su inigualable presencia escénica y
su voz aikitina Turner produjeron éxitos
a lo largo de los años 60 y 70 pasando
al rock
Pero algunas canciones como riverdale
producida por Phil spector y Mountain
High fueron originalmente en 1966
fracasos
[Música]
en blanco y negro en la televisión
italiana canciones como fueron un éxito
en Europa
y en Estados Unidos donde el grupo actuó
en el show de edsolivans
sin embargo su matrimonio era abusivo
divorciándose tuvo que luchar al
principio como Tina Turner solista su
papel en la versión cinematográfica de
Tommy Queen ayudaría
pero fueron
al estrellato
[Música]
y se consolidó el año siguiente en 1985
con Widow para la película Mad Max
[Música]
una incansable presencia escénica éxitos
como debes
y más tarde Golden de 2011 han hecho
cantar y bailar a millones de personas